now I pass the floor to vice president
on graphs keys for the college readout
good afternoon everyone
so in today's press conference will
concentrate on budgetary instrument for
convergence and a competitiveness as
well as on anti money laundering
issues but let me first point out some
other items which were in today's
Commission's agenda today the Commission
has issued guidance on the participation
of certain country bidders in the EU
procurement market this practical advice
for public buyers in a Member States
will help them to help them to deal with
bidders from outside the European Union
this includes clarifications on which
country bidders have secure access to EU
procurement market and which companies
may be exploited our guidance also aims
to raise awareness amongst the
contracting authorities of the different
instruments in the EU public procurement
toolbox this includes measures that may
be taken in case of abnormally low
priced offers as well as measures to
ensure that certainty bidders respect
the same quality as EU bidders in areas
such as security labor and environmental
standards the college also adopted the
19th report on the security union I will
not say much more on this because
Commissioner King will present it was
Olympic Committee in the European
Parliament this afternoon now moving to
the budgetary instrument on
competitiveness and convergence
throughout this Commission's mandate we
have been working on deepening economic
and monetary union in order to make
Europe's economy stronger and more
resilient in June euro summit agreed on
a package with a number of steps in that
direction such as an ESM reform and a
backstop to the banking union to deal
with the banking crisis should they
occur it also includes a budgetary
instrument for convergence and
competitiveness to help our economies
converge upwards today we are proposing
a governance framework for the budgetary
instruments for
convergence and competitiveness this
complements our aerial patrol our
earlier proposal on the reform support
program which has served as a good basis
for discussions by the member states on
an instrument ear of this kind 27 member
states in the inclusive eurosam it
decided that a new instrument should be
available for the euro area and on a
voluntary basis erm to States and that
autonomy of the decision making for euro
area member states should be ensured in
June ahead of the euro summit as a
commission announced it readiness to
propose a new regulation on the basis of
article 136 of the treaty in order to
set up this governance framework within
the existing treaties today we are doing
exactly that as a framework proposed is
fully consistent with our
well-established European semester for
economic policy coordination so how will
it work in short as a euro area member
states will set out annual strategic
orientation for reform and investment
priorities for the euro area as a whole
they will also provide country specific
guidance for reforms and investment
packages to be supported under the
instrument it's important to act now we
want made to make sure that European
Parliament and the council have all the
elements necessary for the work in order
to finish on time
for the next multi-annual financial
framework goonter will speak more on
this in a moment we look forward to the
discussions in European Parliament and
the council once agreement is reached
I'm confident this instrument will prove
to be a valuable tool for making
economic monetary union stronger and
more prosperous today we also adopted a
communication on addressing money
laundering and financing of terrorism
together with a series of reports that
assess risks and remaining shortcomings
we have done a lot to put in use
financial sector and more solid footing
for instance by strengthening the
Prudential requirements
and work is still underway to complete
the banking union and to create a true
capital markets union but a sound
financial sector must also be built on
the highest standards of integrity
serious money laundering scandals
involving a number of banks have
highlighted that Europe needs to do more
on this
there must be no place for money
laundering and terrorist financing in
Europe's banks in response to the call
from the EU finance ministers in
December 2018 our services have analysed
what went wrong
as you know Europe has some of the
toughest rules on money laundering in
the world and our rule book is being
further strengthened yet today's
analysis gives more proof that our
strong AML rules have not been equally
applied in all banks and in all EU
countries to give you a couple of
concrete examples of what did not work
what emerges is a picture of ineffective
compliance or lack of compliance
even when formal procedures are in place
this comes from stuffing and management
capacity issues in some cases but in
many others banks simply did not made
compliance a priority at the same time
as a report revealed and in consistence
report response for supervisors in terms
of timeliness intensity and in terms of
measures taken again they were staffing
and capacity issues and another issue
that was that where credit institutions
had cross-border operations no one
supervisor look to responsibility for
the group as a whole
each supervisor focused on the local
business in that in understate this
points to the structural problem in the
union's capacity to prevent a financial
system as a firm the financial system is
used for illegitimate illegitimate
purposes since these cases happened
banks
supervisors and the you have taken a
number of actions most recently
conferring additional powers to the
European Banking Authority our analysis
suggests that we should pursue the path
towards more competence
the EU level and a single rule book
based on regulations browsers and
directives today's reports prepares the
ground for a new commission to do so and
to take further steps to improve
consistent application of our rules and
ensure strong cross-border coordination
today we also published as a reports
related to unions legal framework for
from preventing money laundering and
terrorist financing as well as how it is
being implemented where we'll provide
you with more details in a moment let me
just say that these important findings
are of concern to us and deserve further
consideration as such they will feed
into decision making process of the next
Commission thank you
ok now Commissioner attina to complete
from the EU budget side my name damn
Kevin we pick up this house Heights
instrumental convergence wind whips a
kite it is the oil fumes clinton puffs
kiss again some also sift the oil
patient households politic said yahan
the foie gras torchon m30 stabile in
feet long and so hydrants a kite vital
instrumental becoming solo for Adam
eigen and also in a household filled
except a lot some household the oil page
you know one piece into instrument in my
household garments
item default label the Yuma Commission
had mid even for Clark to them
Mariel in finance garments and the items
fancy is in the Sun achievements 20 I
was in Soho 65 and thought it went in
help this Europe Asian households and
specialist instrument to the oil hot
sauna
2000 watts omitted startin in my let's
the Ava's focus flood this farm and how
sayest instruments or con Diegans
wouldn't
with verbs fake ID s captain
Satan's fun Christ's sake it's Valley
woman went missing it's done part as a
skill in con una Satine and set sail in
the oil hot sauna the weight gain of the
Quinta this commissions for slugs
nirvana - plain skin whatever amount of
DA room
this is to convey transformed hunt we
beaten get them in the Silverado iron
woman house eyelids Raman taught us next
day out st. multivitamin teasing me are
apt reasons to the Latin wonderful
option this wagon van meer emissary
stick that's thesis or what Sony
instrument needs I know Suzette's info
to go home the suicides garments field
in Australia tile the suicides famines
assign at noon Humvee are me twisting
him off track this road Solan lattice
their finance minister after starting
like young chefs in the Commission
each toy room slamming it was the
governance which las vidas instrumented
Zukunft cannot ascertain soil I
instrument does a foreman under streets
and soil when does priority unless it's
urine would in as those project
co-financed Ian so damn it happened view
in the hold of carbon came out as liquid
I'm heartened innovator entire Ottoman
doesn't have a parliament people to
hurry to enjoy it English proficiency
stateside so this is even Yara
an exampie tracfone 16 million euro they
are very in some houses German only
problem it does tell part in UN's of
instrument usually at an infant
fulfillment 20 million euro focusing 60
million in Sydney on cinta an offender
the Africa anthem open environment is a
betrayal sty Concannon VT stanchion
solve is even insulting better after
veteran / Otto Allison alum is dammit to
October 30 forbade him after October
when often victim October the oil hot
zone a finance minister at least in the
rotten old and each doesn't like young
chefs often the committee October
symmetry appoint Tim how's that it's
common and naman so it is Niram yes
become focused piston Duncan Thank You
Commissioner now commissioner you
revamped yeah thank you very much we're
definitely and gentlemen I'd like to
come back to the antique money
laundering issue and the reports which
we presented today to the college
through the reports we look at the
anti-money laundering framework in the
whole European Union in a systemic way
to learn the lessons and address the
shortcomings we have a problem in Europe
Europe estimates that around one percent
of Europe's wealth is involved in
suspect financial activity that's the
equivalent of the annual EU budget so
what we did today is firstly to assess
the risks we identified that the biggest
risks are linked to anonymous
transactions like prepaid cards to
virtual currencies and lack of
transparency on beneficial ownership as
a regulator the Commission has already
acted by strengthening the rules we did
the right thing as the force and the
fifths anti-money laundering directives
address these new risks we identified
not all rules are applicable yet as the
latest update has to be transposed in
January 2020 only so I am not afraid to
say that Europe has one of the strongest
anti-money laundering rules in place but
then these rules also need to be
vigorously enforced we have used the
past cases of money laundering scandals
to look at the enforcement
the conclusion is that Member States
supervisors and financial intelligence
units are not always doing enough
especially when it comes to cross-border
cooperation the money flows very easily
between EU countries financial systems
so should the information between
financial intelligence units but as I
said before this is not always the case
also banks with branches in different
member states were not well supervised
as neither the supervisors in the host
country nor in the country of origin
would take the responsibility so we
conclude that reinforcement is not
proactive and disuse if enough the banks
also must do more they were prioritizing
some of their other obligations but
didn't look closely enough where the
money comes from especially following
the crisis so we have tried to address
this too by playing our role as guardian
of the treaty and opening infringement
procedures and by strengthening the role
of the European Banking Authority by
giving it the power to put in place a
preventive and proactive supervision the
price of a failure is high and in each
and every meeting I have with EU
ministers on this issue I am reassured
that the political rail is growing to
tackle this issue as the president-elect
has indicated in her political
guidelines
supervision has to become more effective
and remaining loopholes need to be
filled so I am sure the next commission
will continue to lead these efforts
finally there is also an important
external dimension to our anti money
laundering
toolbox the identification of high-risk
certain countries following the
rejection of the Commission's list by
the council this year in spring we have
worked on a refined methodology to
address the concerns of the Member
States I will continue this work and
will move it to the political level at
the October a coffin Council
I will also discuss it with the European
Parliament
we have also strengthened the
Commission's activity in the financial
action task force in April this task
force agreed on strategic review that
will make its listing process more
risk-based and in June just to remind
you of a case of Panama cut off edit
Panama to its list on high-risk third
countries confirming in fact the
assessment will be made in February but
I can share with you my feeling that's
frustrating this fact that the council
and the European Parliament take very
divergent approaches on this issue the
effect is that we are lagging behind as
our latest update to the list of
high-risk countries comes from mid 2018
I am determined to find a solution and I
am hopeful that we can reach the
agreement that would defend the EU
financial system from the risk coming
from outside the EU I also presented
today the report on gender data
protection regulation so I can yes of
continue another topic as you know we
are one year after the direct
application of our new data protection
regime it is time to assess where we are
there are three main conclusions from
our assessment one data protection
finally matters and people are starting
to care about their privacy - the EU is
entering a digital era on a strong
footing as data protection rules become
an integral part of other policies such
as for instance on artificial
intelligence and three beyond Europe our
data protection rules open up
possibilities for digital diplomacy to
promote data flows based on high
standards between countries that share
EU values we need to continue our work
for the GDP are to become fully
operational and if
if this is what this communication is
all about we see that harmonization of
data protection rules across the EU is
progressing but we the Commission have
to be vigilant so the member states
won't be tempted to take advantage of
some specificities they could include in
their national laws we must avoid the so
called
gold plating the Commission will do its
job on the of the guardian of the
treaties vigorously on this front then
we see that the majority of the citizens
know the rules
they know how to address them cut our
complaints to National Data Protection
Authority but we have to continue
raising awareness so people get a better
understanding of the risks especially in
the digital world and so the businesses
it's true that today they complain much
less as they see that the doom scenarios
of last spring did not materialize they
start to see advantages such as
increased security of data lowering the
costs of breaches innovative privacy
friendly solutions and finally privacy
by design as a competitive
differentiator more and more companies
want to gain people's trust by
respecting their privacy but still too
many companies especially small and
medium enterprises feel uncertain about
the GDP our that's why we continue to
support the data protection authorities
with funds for campaigns and why we urge
the European Data Protection Board to
step up work on facilitating life for
business by using innovative solutions
such as standard contract or clauses
code of conduct or or certification this
is a toolbox gdpr offers to help with
compliance and create more certainty for
companies finally let me say a few words
about where we are with GDP are on the
international stage indeed through GDP
our Europe became the rule maker for the
world
and we can say today the gdpr has become
a reference point of a modern and high
digital stand out more and more
countries in Asia Latin America or
Africa are adopting new laws or changing
their existing ones and are taking the
GD P R as a reference point this is a
true example of the EU as a rule maker
which I mentioned before
also the Eric Ross agreement with Japan
next to the trade agreement is also
something that other countries want to
replicate I went to Chile and Argentina
two weeks ago Chile is working on the
first-ever comprehensive data protection
law taking inspiration from the GD P R
and wants to be engaged in autocracy
talks as soon as possible
Argentina is also changing their law
this is important in the context of our
trade agreements with both countries in
the future and building on the Japanese
idea of data flows was thrust and on the
Council of Europe Convention 108 I see
scope for more multilateral rulemaking
in the area of privacy rules in the
digital world and the EU can be and
should be a leader in this process we
must not still stand still however this
is why the communication contains a
to-do list for everyone for the Member
States for the European data protection
board for the data protection
authorities for the Commission GDP our
can only fully succeed if we have
uniform application and robust
enforcement across the EU and when we
will develop an eu-wide culture in this
area if you remember and we were
adopting GD P R we promised one law one
continent and this has to be maintained
so this will also be an important
contribution for the review of the GD P
R which the new Commission will have to
do in spring 2020 thank you very much
thank you very much
commissioners and vice-president let's
see open the floor to questions I had
her first
good morning Kolkata go with your active
two questions one for what - for
Commissioner Dombrowski's one of them
might be also for commissioner over
oh no the money laundering it seems that
the EU even though it's putting forward
always new initiative is goes one step
behind one of the issues discussed is
having a fine European authority to
handle antimony laundering cases so do
you think that for the next Commission
on you vice-president burski will be
part of the next Commission having this
authority is a mark and not only limit
in having an urbanized implementation of
the new rules and a second question also
for Commissioner Dombrowski's the public
prosecutor in Spain has filed charges
against the BBVA which is as you know
the second largest bank in Spain for
other reasons illegal wiretapping so my
question is whether are you concerned
about this this situation given that is
not only a systemic bank but the second
largest bank in Spain and also if you
consider that the bank should take
forceful action given that the
governor's it has take and the whole
entity has been again put in five
charges very first searches thank you
well on the first question on anti money
laundering and indeed putting more
authority as a level indeed that's what
our communication suggested we should
have and dedicated antique money
laundering authority in the EU we do not
currently go in detail whether it's on
the basis of European banking
authorities which already have assigned
more powers during the review of
European supervisory authorities or is
it some other institution so we are in
this sense not prejudging the work of
the new
commission we also outlines that for
european authority to act more
effectively it will be helpful actually
to have a single rule book based on
regulations instead of directives as it
is now because then for european
authority it's easier to enforce
european regulations and national laws
which are transposing directives so we
do do hope of course that this is going
to be priority also for the next
European Commission and that there is
going to be follow-up on this report as
as regards currently I don't how much
comments to make as it was currently
with national authorities okay that
answered your question no you had one
more that was not answered it is not
only a national authority competence
because actually as the single
supervisor is the ECB I mean there is a
funky look I mean a European role here
in order to play and one of those
aspects that the ECB and the super
signal supervisor monitors is the the
proper governance of the systemic one so
I guess that either they CV single
supervisor on the Commission may be half
award to same what actions the ECB port
must take in order to ensure the proper
governance comments and can make from
European Commission side ECB as you know
is a independent institution in this
case you should address this question to
see me okay then I Jim next
thank you thank you very much Jim
Bronstein from the Financial Times
um actually the first question is it's
just it's a follow-up to Jorge's
question actually is there scope for
other authorities other than the EBA to
to get involved with this and I think
we've seen recently what the limitations
of the EBA are I mean frankly it buried
its own report into the danske bank
scandal so it hasn't exactly covered
itself in glory and secondly on a
different topic would it be possible to
have some reflections from the
commissioners present on the the
Commission's the Commission's now
departing secretary general and what
they felt about his performance in
office thank you very much okay so on
which exactly European Authority should
it be dealing with AML questions as I
said our communication leaves this
question open so we have identified this
as a structural problems that
enforcement even though we have European
rules and one of the strongest through
rules anti-money laundering rules in the
world enforcement so far has been purely
national and very uneven so we think
that we can deal with this assigning
more authority at the EU level whether
it's European bank authority or some
other institution we currently use this
issue open other guards European Banking
Authority and you mentioned bans danske
bank case indeed we have also voiced our
disappointment of this decision not to
investigate
danske bank case but it must be noted
that when we were proposing the review
of European Supervisory authorities we
were also proposing more far-reaching
changes to that governance of European
Supervisory authorities to allow for
more effective decision-making and maybe
this Danske Bank case is a good
indication that we should come back to
this question okay then Commissioner I
think a first on the point our
secretary-general
nothing seemed Irish items I was a
commission okay twins now Esther a
hundred the overpaid community or
intimate our instigate Commission's
president in in analytic mcleach that
certain sign of the incessant cloudy bar
cereal in Vic
I don't cloud in cabinet for forgetting
about them here cabinet chef I had short
load younger Upton Easton tag in the for
per item of TC commission epic lightened
Visayan v6 the bharata-varsa in
cabinetry fondest Windsor Connecticut
air is next a balaclava different theory
short or jumbo commission Viren or
assign a metal comb in their forms nice
thing by happy I'll put it in the
balance
notice verse eight the finish continued
haven't afore kill Isis at miss keener
oesterreich
router Street East novelty / willful
curiosity so bike lovers the next
president in the occasion Commission and
it told to start spillin East
ballast my lead intestine de ganar
Isaac's here
least declare a nationality it hadn't
started had fallen away in the heart
navigated through collective next to her
house when it's lava
demises in Tim dampened hedonist and
passing time two minutes respect for him
okay tank Commission euro I wanted to
add something I'd like to come back to
the topic of the money laundering and
European possibly European supervisory
body at this moment became of the
European Banking Authority we see that
they react exposed
upon request they investigated into two
cases and that's why also taking this
lesson seriously we want the EBA to have
stronger powers to be able to collect
the data to to
the early detection of some risky
behavior and to take proactive and
preventive measures and this would be
even strengthened in the future as
Modi's indicated but I think that taking
lessons and looking for the solutions we
should be also a little bit creative and
look into what are other capacities of
the EU having which we have in fight
against financial crime and in my view
it would be worthwhile thinking about
the possible role of the European Public
Prosecutor's Office
up to now we spoke about preventive and
proactive work but when it comes to last
resort action which is criminal justice
fear there the European Public
Prosecutor's Office the EPP Oh should
play more and more important role in the
EU because this will be the pan-european
operating body in playing very important
role in fighting against financial crime
there will be capacities there will be
prosecutors specialized on on financial
crime and as such it could be a body
which could play stronger role in
prosecuting the crime related also to
money laundering this is my personal
view this is how I see the situation of
course it will be for the Commission to
look into this possibility it will be
for the European Parliament and Member
States in case such as such a proposal
would come in the future whether this
would be practical and efficient I want
to just to remind us of the fact that
every possible enlarging of the
competences of the EPP Oh would require
unanimity from the side of the state so
very strong come on our court but I do
believe that it is worth thinking about
also not only preventive but also
repressive side thank you ok I have
quite a number on my list all this you
please sir exactly yes no not you
Jennifer colleague behind you sorry
Ilse no gallatin television I have a
president a question for the vice
president Dombrowski's who is to replace
Martin so Meyer a secretary-general at
least for now
thank you well as regards
secretary-general it's you concerned so
current deputy secretary general who is
replacing Martin Selma and becoming
acting secretary general okay then I had
next actually Jennifer yes thank you
very much Jennifer Rankin from The
Guardian and to return to my anti money
laundering the report identifies
Freeport's as as a risk area as a
vulnerability for the EU when it comes
to and when it comes to money laundering
why is it only now that the Commission
is looking at free ports as they've
existed for a long time and can you give
us a flavor of where you see the risks
in free ports and is it appropriate to
have so many free ports in the European
Union and just a second question if I
may given the cross-border nature of
what you are discussing do you think the
EU current rules are brexit proof well I
will probably start with second question
well as regards use anti money
laundering rules as we already were
saying as they are one of the strictest
in the world so from that point of view
I would say it's irregardless of breaks
is that we have strong anti money
laundering legislation so the question
here is how this anti money laundering
legislation is being applied and that's
what we are currently concentrating on
so how to improve enforcement within the
EU of course and there always remains
questions of this money being laundered
often comes from the third countries or
ends up in a third countries this is
also the
which you're touching up into this
report did you want anything
commissioner on the three ports we are
mentioning the new new trends and and
the risks which are becoming more
dangerous and which are achieving some
to say critical mass of problems so
among those new risks and new trends we
see virtual currencies also the
citizenship for sale and URI data free
ports are mentioned there this is not a
new thing but now we came to a
conclusion after a thorough analysis of
the issues that it is worth mentioning
and it is worth specifically addressing
in the report so this is not a new thing
but we want to we wanted to analyze this
issue and come with the explanation that
this is something we have to focus more
on that's cleared the middle question to
commissioner yova which parts of the
implementation of the gdp are called the
most worry for you which rights of the
gdp are you of you are not sufficiently
you know widespread amongst citizens
awareness and specifically thinking
about the right that you can actually
know if a decision about you for example
in the insurance market or in the labor
market is being made by some automated
algorithmic procedure and i think you
publish to europe barometz who recently
that shows that actually basically
nobody knows about this right and it's
getting more more important as more and
more aspects of our lives are being
ultimate eyes thank you
wow you came at the same time is the
answer because this is the whole range
of issues related to the informed
consent of the people because they
should know at every moment what's
happening to their data what's happened
to their identity after they shared
their private data with some system and
this is the most difficult thing also I
think for the businesses to comply with
this strict rule but we could not do
otherwise then insist on well informed
consent as the basic principle because
we wanted to give back to the people the
control over their data and indeed this
is gaining more importance when we speak
about the rules for artificial
intelligence and the systems based on
algorithms because in this we insist on
having the food transparency and having
the good knowledge and having good
control over how the algorithm is set up
and also to give the people the chance
to know how the assessment is is done so
the informed consent and to to
compliance with this strict rule then
speaking about the main issues in
implementation in some countries as I
said also in the speech we we see some
kind of gold plating some countries go
beyond the GDP are to my taste too far
and then the people cease to understand
why GDP are is setting some some rules
because simply GDP are is risk-based
Rousseau when the countries go beyond
and introduce burdensome unnecessary
measures for some sectors will see this
as a problem then the third problem
which I see personally as a dangerous
indication or trend in some countries we
see that GDP are appears in the crash
with the freedom of media and right
right for information we have to clarify
with several states that GDP are is not
there to deprive the people of the right
of information so these are the three
things which are defect
and when I said the one continent one
law we still work hard on through
ongoing dialogue as the member states to
keep the consistent application and not
to go beyond what the GDP I wanted then
I had Jack or that is cleared follow up
on Jennifer's question on free ports I
just wondered if you had specific
concerns that the idea of new free ports
being opened in Europe is this is this
an issue that you'll continue to look at
or will look at again and might there be
guidelines or advice for any any
existing or future free ports than my
existent just very shortly of course the
fact that we mentioned the free ports as
the new emerging threat this is the
invitation for the follow-up and for
looking more deeply into into the issue
and coming with the recommendation for
the sector thank you okay then I did
have miss you next
there's named Commissioner Matthew
Newman from endlich's just to follow up
on a previous question about gdpr and
implementation you mentioned several
difficulties that you see in GDP our
implementation gold plating and such are
you at all looking at letters of formal
notice or any kind of first steps in
infringement procedure and and also in
your speech you mentioned making it
easier for businesses as a priority for
you and this is standard contractual
contracts and code of conduct and that
kind of thing I was wondering where you
are
with that if you've been thinking about
doing the new model contracts
perhaps with processor to processor and
when that might come out if at all maybe
before the end of this mandate and then
finally you mentioned the priority about
GDP are around the world as a standard
can you just give us an update which
countries are the farthest advanced in
your talks with adequacy or possible
adequate adequacy agreements thanks very
much we said from the beginning that we
will not hesitate to a launch
infringement procedure were needed and
that's why I said before that we are
still in the dialogue with the member
states trying to improve the situation
to discourage some member states from
adopting the national legislation where
we see the the possible deviation but in
case we will see this necessary of
course we will we will use the legal
traditional process which which might be
even the latter form a notice in some
cases on how to help the businesses of
course the certification for instance or
the code of conduct these are the tools
which might help not only businesses in
general but specific sectors because
after all so before GDP I came into
force
we received tens of thousands of
questions from the business world and
each of those questions were specific it
is simply not one size fits all and the
risk-based approach means that each
company has to assess its own risk
because it is a specific situation
that's why we believe that the more
guidelines and more tools like a
certification and codes of conducts will
help
and here we rely on data protection
authorities who are in touch with
reality to work intensively on these
tools because this will be also help for
them if these tools will not work in
practice the avalanche of the questions
will continue and the last question it
was something I liked of course
we made a sort of analysis of the
situation in the world and there are
more than 100 countries which now have
the laws similar to the GDP are our main
comparison benchmark is without the
protection of privacy is recognized in
the country as fundamental right so with
such countries we engaged in the
dialogue or we finalized Japanese
adequacy decision which is a mutual one
we are on a good track in South Korea we
want to do more with Latin America we
have to review all the current capacity
sessions we have 11 states which have
the loss which have to be compared with
GDP are in order to renew possibly renew
the air across a decision so this is the
bilateral work a very sort of analytical
work we doing this we see everywhere
that the GDP are as the more and more
important global
standard is recognized so it's very
logical that the the EU is assessing the
situation and other countries based on
under GT GPR and by the way the European
Court of Justice said clearly that to
allow the data transfers from EU
somewhere else
it requires to have the essentially
equivalent protection on all the other
place which is the condition for
possible equalities at across a position
but more strategic vision might be this
multilateral agreement which would
create a big wealth white space for free
flow of data with trust which was the
Japanese idea I agree with it that this
might be the the good way forward and
which could also work as a intensive for
the states which do not recognize the
protection of privacy as fundamental
right and which should be under more
pressure from our side from the side of
those who take this very seriously
okay then two more questions because I
think time is running out Chris dad I
was next
Mexico gue say it is held up a store
Espanola
a female a [ __ ] oh monsieur le
Commissaire villa kini position position
of accounts Miyano la loc invoke a
Luminos todo nephew commando you know
poor explica important stole a politican
and a una mantle de la contamination and
gentle dalla Villa de Luna P oppressor
ilaha il-allah tribunal de luxe Ambo
Sisto Segovia Nemo du mal Spain Brazil
chorus river or sea mmmm shimma shimma
reservoir c vu Santi collar Politico
ambient r8 engrave a shack in the Water
Commission
okay ceremony is a college readout don't
you comment a co the possible infraction
keen on it a discotheque Alicia road we
Thomas a seizure con Olivia where to ass
you
sickest job condylar Tom we Crusader
spam civilly over say Prescott I found
over to Amanda
yes Eastern f Google Newman genetic
invoke a permissive a lucky name is
usually Keeshond Avila grew a pair emo
ratio sniper Feeny Maquis to Nepal water
disinfection Jimmy reservoir come over
Santi with la política ornamental is
considered a nice shake the vato
Commission a seaman prison since the
pass he on the Commission said Christian
require interested in Christian as a
general danke le coup de independencia
yank all the depositions and called
Ivana call on that employer comment II
don't care to O'Donnell a possibility
recollect you and the questions you let
them do so via City the callate la the
pushin
okay but Commissioner acting a perhaps
they wants to add something that
soon-to-be Austin Lima suits is tiny
europe-asia
of Kharkov warden i'ma teach Darden and
a killin and as Europe Asia Union here
give mine some after it nah even see cos
Phi M students Luke Jones
see The Gazette stat you know iron held
na Heusen impotency Marrakesh in
Katowice thieves target craft travel
training the team are shooting for
elevator he asked if I'm bound a
botanist in Fightin's
in my mouth a German so teases yachts
ain't have the isthmus bit mainstreaming
and 20% Lima should still focusing
wouldn't arrive eNOS 20% oonski Oscar 20
cent pour oil
Mustafa is part of commitments I'm Kenny
China for clash para
seals its own didn't household convicts
the instrument so Timur should aim at
this welcome via makes the obtained of
food report in Saigon each club at the
prison via there's a Waco isn't teaming
the myriad
hope astronaut world unwell Fatima suits
in spray in dalian with this far
included Naumann million coming soon
okay merci beaucoup
Thank You Samuel stole turn your active
here I'm going back to GDP our
Commissioner you're over I'd like to
know if you've got a message for Greece
Portugal and Slovenia who are actually
yet to update their national rules to
fall in line with GDP are and why do you
think they've been dragging their feet
in making the changes I have a message
for them and they know it hurry up